edith et marcel ensemble un sourire
celui des deux plus grandes vedettes du
moment
un regard celui bouleversant de deux
amants un mystère cette folle passion
qui s'écrit au présent mon adoré pensent
tant d'amour qui va s'échapper de mes
yeux de ma bouche de mon coeur tant de
bonheur qui va nous éclabousser temps de
soleil qui se mettra dans nos âmes et
tant de chaleur qui va nous brûler l'un
et l'autre est dit chéri il y à une
élite piaf et j'ai la chance moi pauvre
brut de boxeurs d'être aimé par elle
mais c'est merveilleux je viens rêve
chéri c'est avec moi que tu rentre le
soir et qui couche là contre moi six
mois correspondance pour dire le trouble
le désir l'absence passion clandestine
cerdan est marié père de trois enfants
alors les lettres ne sont jamais signé
ou plutôt si toi moi moi pour toit les
deux amants leur paradis les états unis
elle y chante il boxe
ils s'aiment et s'enchante vraiment et
ludo l'attrait beaucoup d'autres dans sa
vie et l'ont déçu édité salle l'a dit a
dit serge était saoul ont déçu les ans
les uns venaient pour profiter de sa
gloire à elle pour devenir eux-mêmes
venait lui marcel n'avait pas besoin de
ça donc c'était vraiment l'amour ça sert
l'amour pur
non mais l'amour tu es toute ma vie
entière je t'appartiens pour toujours
oui mon chéri pour toujours je suis ta
petite à tout petit tienne moi chérie je
crois que tous les français sont au
courant de notre histoire car quand
j'arrive dans un restaurant français il
y a immédiatement la chanson la vie en
rose qui s'élève et je crois qu'on doit
avoir la gueule que je fais que ça doit
me faire quelque chose
la belle histoire s'arrête quelque part
dans le ciel entre paris et new york en
octobre 49 faire donc bien reprendre son
titre mondial perdu quatre mois plus tôt
contre jack la motta
il veut prendre le bateau est des plus
supplie de la résoudre au plus et le
corps de marcel et identifiés grâce à sa
montre un cadeau des digues
ce soir-là effondrée elle trouvera
pourtant la force de chanter reste le
plus beau le plus émouvant des
testaments cet hymne à l'amour qu'elle
dédiera jusqu'à sa mort à son amour de
champion une chanson et des lettres
brûlante liebrandt seul témoin d'un
amour de légende foudre rond